let me ask you about uh something that
you know I think about a little bit in
this modern world which is monogamy
so I personally value monogamy one girl
ride or die there you go right or not
that's exactly it but that said
I'd I don't know what's the right way to
approach this but
from an evolutionary biology perspective
or from just looking at modern society
that seems to be an idea that's not
what's the right way to put it
flourishing
it is waning it's waning
um so I suppose based on your reaction
you're also a supporter of monogamy or
the you value monogamy are you and I
just
um delusional
um what can you say about monogamy from
the context of your book from the
context of evolutionary biology from the
context of Being Human yeah I can say
that I fully believe that we are
actually enlightened and that although
monogamy is waning that it is not waning
because there is a superior system it is
waiting for predictable other reasons
so
let us just say it is there's a lot of
pre-trans fallacy here where
people go through a phase where they
recognize that actually we know a lot
about the evolution of monogamy and we
can tell from the fact that humans are
somewhat sexually dimorphic that there
has been a lot of polygyny in human
history
and in fact most of human history was
largely polygenous but it is also the
case that most of the people on Earth
today belong to civilizations that are
at least nominally monogamous and have
practiced monogamy and that's not
anti-evolutionary what that is is part
of what I mentioned before where human
beings can swap out their software
program
and different mating patterns are uh
favored in different periods of History
so I would argue that the benefit of
monogamy the primary one that drives the
evolution of monogamous patterns in
humans is that it brings all adults into
child rearing
now the reason that that matters is
because human babies are very labor
intensive in order to raise them
properly having two parents is a huge
asset and having more than two parents
having an extended family also very
important
but what that means
is that for a population that is
expanding
and monogamous mating system makes sense
it makes sense because it means that the
number of offspring that can be raised
is elevated it's elevated because all
potential parents are involved in
parenting whereas if you sideline a
bunch of males by having a polygenous
system in which one male has many
females which is typically the way that
works what you do is you sideline all
those males which means the total amount
of Parental effort is lower and the
population can't grow so what what I'm
arguing is that you should expect to see
populations that face the possibility of
expansion endorse monogamy and at the
point that they have reached carrying
capacity you should expect to see
polygeny break back out and what we are
seeing is a kind of false sophistication
around polyamory which will end up
breaking down into polygyny which will
not be in the interest of most people
really the only people who's interested
could be argued to be in would be the
very small number of males at the top
who have many partners and everybody
else suffers is it possible to make the
argument if we focus in on those males
at the quote-unquote top with the many
female Partners is it possible to say
that that's a sub-optimal life
that a single partner is the optimal
life well it depends what you mean I
have a feeling that you and I wouldn't
have to go very far to figure out that
um what might be evolutionarily optimal
doesn't match my values as a person and
I'm sure it doesn't match yours either
you know try to can we try to dig into
the that gap between those two sure
um I mean we can do it very simply uh
selection might favor your engaging in
war against a defenseless enemy or
genocide
right it's not hard to figure out how
that might put your genes at advantage
I don't know about you Lex I'm not
getting involved in no genocide it's not
going to happen I won't do it I will do
anything to avoid it so some part of me
has decided that my conscious self and
the values that I hold Trump my
evolutionary self
and
once you figure out that in some extreme
case that's true and then you realize
that that means it must be possible in
many other cases and you start going
through all of the things that selection
would favor and you realize that a fair
fraction of the time actually you're not
up for this you don't want to be some
robot on a mission that involves
genocide when necessary you want to be
your own person and accomplish things
that you think are valuable
and so among those
are not advocating you know let's
suppose you're in a position to be one
of those males at the top of a
polygenous system we both know why that
would be rewarding right but we also
both recognize it yeah sure lots of sex
yeah okay what else lots of sex and lots
of variety right so look
every red-blooded American slash Russian
male could understand why that's
appealing right on the other hand it is
up against an alternative which is
having a partner with whom one is bonded
especially closely right right and so
hey love right well you know I don't
want to I don't wanna uh straw man the
polygamy position obviously polygeny is
complex and there's nothing that stops a
man presumably from loving multiple
partners and from them loving him back
but in terms of you know if love is your
thing there's a question about okay what
is the quality of love if it is divided
over multiple partners right and what is
the net consequence for love in a
society when multiple people will be
frozen out for every individual male in
this case who has it
um and what I would argue
is and you know this is weird to even
talk about but this is partially me just
talking from personal experience I think
there actually is a monogamy program in
us and it's not automatic but if you
take it seriously you can find it and
frankly marriage and it doesn't have to
be marriage but whatever it is that
results in the lifelong bond with a
partner has gotten a very bad rap you
know it's the butt of too many jokes but
the truth is it's hugely rewarding it's
not easy but if you know that you're
looking for something right if you know
that the objective actually exists and
it's not some utopian fantasy that can't
be found if you know that there's some
real world you know warts and all
version of it then you might actually
think hey that is something I want and
you might pursue it and my guess is
you'd be very happy when you find it
yeah I think there is uh getting to the
fundamentals of the emergent I feel like
there is some kind of physics of love so
one we there's a conservation thing
going on so if you have like many
partners
yeah in theory you should be able to
love all of them deeply but it seems
like in reality that love gets split
yep now there's another law that's
interesting in terms of monogamy I I
don't know if it's at the physics level
but if you are in a monogamous
relationship by choice
and almost as
um in slight Rebellion to social norms
that's much more powerful like if you
choose that one partnership that's also
more powerful if you if like everybody's
in a monogamous there's this pressure to
be married in this pressure of society
that's different because that's almost
like a constraint on your freedom that
is enforced by something other than your
own ideals it's by by somebody else when
you yourself choose to I guess create
these constraints that enriches that
love so there's some kind of love
function
like E equals MC squared but for love
that I feel like if you have less
partners and is done by choice that can
maximize that and that love can
transcend the biology Transcendent
evolutionary biology forces that have to
do much more with survival and all those
kinds of things it can transcend to take
us to to a richer experience which will
have the luxury of having exploring of
Happiness of of Joy or fulfillment all
those kinds of things totally agree with
us and there's no question that by
choice when there are other choices
imbues it with meaning that it might not
otherwise have I would also say you know
I'm
I'm really struck by and I have a hard
time not feeling
terrible sadness over
what
younger people are coming to think about
this topic
I think they're missing something so
important and so hard to phrase that and
they don't even know that they're
missing it
they might know that they're unhappy but
they don't understand what it is they're
even looking for because nobody's really
been honest with them about what their
choices are and I have to say
if I was a young person or if I was
advising a young person which I used to
do again a million years ago when I was
a college professor four years ago
um but I used to you know talk to
students I knew my students really well
and they would ask questions about this
and they were always curious because
Heather and I seemed to have a good
relationship and many of them knew both
of us so they would talk to us about
this
if I was advising somebody I would say
Do not bypass the possibility that what
you are supposed to do is find somebody
Worthy
somebody who can handle it somebody who
you are compatible with and then you
don't have to be perfectly compatible
it's not about dating until you find the
one it's about finding somebody who's
underlying values and Viewpoint are
complementary to yours sufficient that
you fall in love
if you find that person
opt out together
get out of this damn system that's
telling you what's sophisticated to
think about love and romance and sex
ignore it together right that's the key
and I believe you'll end up laughing in
the end if you do it you'll discover
wow that's a hellscape that I opted out
of and this thing I opted into
complicated difficult worth it nothing
that's worth it is ever not difficult so
we should we should even just skip the
whole statement about difficult yeah all
right I just I want to be honest it's
not like oh it's you know it's non-stop
Joy no it's freaking complex but
um but worth it no question in my mind